alors je vais vous faire une petite
interview où est-ce qu'on peut baisser
la lumière en un beau cheval dans le
dinner
laurent baffie ne sera pas là la semaine
prochaine bien alors ces quatre
questions qu'est ce qui vous rend vert
de rage pédophilie ce touriste sexuel
qu'est ce qui vous rend rouge de honte
quand je me marre en scène c'est à dire
quand moi même un d'un spectacle je suis
pris par le rire d'un spectateur une
étude ac ou pas je me marie la géante
qu'est ce qui peut vous rendre bleus de
peur est reconnue dans la rue à part un
raconteur d'histoires kim entreprend et
je vous parle d'une histoire arrivée
c'est à dire beaubourg au diront avec un
mec alors c'est un type qui rentre dans
un café et le thé au bape est alors
l'autre histoire ces bactéries
c'est ma terreur qu'est ce qu'ils
voudront du pêcheur qu'est ce qui vous
rend rose le bonheur au petit garçon
t'es bon
bien